we will practice going between reference
ramps to look at relative velocities in
one dimension let's say that an observer
is standing on the sidewalk and that
observer sees a car drive past to the
right at a speed of the car the observer
also sees a bike that's riding to the
left at a slower speed V bike now I'm
interested in what the car looks like
from the perspective of the bike the
bike sees itself as stationary and sees
the world around it moving to the right
to the bike the observer on the sidewalk
appears to be moving to the right with a
speed of the bike the car was moving to
the right relative to the reference
frame of the observer sitting on the
sidewalk so to the bike the car looks
like it's going even faster to the right
with a total speed of the car plus the
bike let's say later on the biker throws
an apple in the direction of her
movement and sees this Apple travel to
the left with a speed of ve EPEL now I
want to know what an observer sees in
the stationary frame on the sidewalk the
Apple appears to be traveling a speed V
Apple faster than the biker all to the
left so the observer on the sidewalk
will see the Apple move to the left with
a total speed of the Apple plus V bike
now let's say the person throws the
Apple Ford at a speed V Apple what does
the car seat to the car the Apple is
going to the left at a speed of the car
- the Apple how about the bike to the
bike the Apple is going at a speed of
the Apple plus V bike to the right